hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video Rebecca on fawn again today is
Thursday it's test you're me cap day we
got some stuff to talk about little few
things talking about in season 11 with
one thing coming from the patch as well
as an emo contest going over the patch
from a couple days ago as well as going
you know reminiscing back to the old
days of foreigner but yeah as always
like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being balanced changes here updates
pageants and leaks gonna be kept up
today with everything happening within
the warmer corner definitely stay
subscribe to the channel that guys let's
get right into this video so first stuff
we have a sale I believe most if not all
signatures are going to be going on sale
today they're gonna be 3k steel as
opposed to 5k still so that's really
interesting also a little bit later into
the stream they showed off some of the
old III chips from years ago and my god
men did these look absolutely ancient I
haven't seen these Trevor's and so long
and it was kind of nice and refreshing
to see them again the first two were
back in the game when Marta before
marching fire before season 2 or me all
that stuff way before the game even
released and we had the trailer from the
story mode with apollyon then we had the
multiplayer type of showcase it was
really cool to see that and then leading
up all the way to the latest III that
they went to where they showed off the
marching fire trailer which and there's
no argument for this this was without a
doubt the most hyped seasonal foreigner
regardless of how it actually turned out
everybody was literally hyped to play
this season you got to remember we had
that huge teaser when Tiana B was
striking the warden at the time we
didn't even know who T on D was and we
had no idea what the sword was people
are speculating people otter was
Persians Egyptians pirates no one
expected the Wulin really at all so that
was really cool to see that everybody
was hyped to see what the hell was going
on even though the season in actuality
was okay and some of the characters were
semi broken with bad animations and
really high damage output
I still got chills from this trailer and
everybody was still hyped before it came
out of course and honestly if I had to
choose a season if I could just replay
the music back and forth every time I
would load up the game it would have to
be marching fire next they talked about
the patch notes and in specific the one
going live today which is patched 2.10 I
covered this a couple days ago so I do
recommend watching that video if you
want to see the entire video it will be
linked in the top right in a second but
I do have to clarify there was a huge
mistake that I said
yes of those couple days ago and I want
to make it right in this video and try
to do some damage control I said in the
video that Rader got a buff increasing
his stamina damage for the stunning tat
from 20 to 30 this is actually incorrect
before the patch went live on June 5th
and before stunning tap would take you
to 20 damage so if you had a hundred
stamina full stamina and you got hit
with stunning tap you would instantly go
to 20
technically losing 80 but now it just
takes away 30 so instead of going from a
hundred stamina up to 20 you now go from
100 to 70 then if you get hit again it
goes from 70 to 40 so it's actually a
nerf I just looked through the the
numbers and I thought that it went from
20 to 30 that was my fault I didn't
actually think that that was the case
but yeah it is actually nerf I just
wanted to clarify that before you watch
that video cuz I do say it wrong in that
video so I just want to let everybody
know oh yeah that'll be the end of this
video in the endcard or in the
annotation in the top right coming up
now we got some Raider nerfs la bring
your box above bug fixes but sadly no
glad guard stands coming so but
hopefully we'll get that soon but yeah
if you want to check out that video and
get up-to-date on what's happening with
today's patch that's going live today
yeah then definitely check out that
video right now one of the things that
they mentioned was the shaman throw
distance nerf and the same with the
warlord throw distance nerf was actually
a little bit of a teaser they said
people may be confused why we're doing
this but it will make a lot of sense in
year 3 season 3 or season 11 they're
doing this now as in regards to a future
patch coming within season 11 so I have
no clue what that even means
I would love to speculate in the
comments below but I think that'd look
good I mean that sounds good to me I
don't know exactly what that means at
all I don't know cuz it's the stamina
it's the throw distance so I'm not
really sure what kind of huge mechanic
that they're gonna be adding that
they're gonna be able to change
something with throw distance maybe
there won't be as much ledges anymore
for season 11 but who knows I'd love to
know what you guys think in the comments
below cuz I'm absolutely dumbfounded by
this and then next we have the for honor
emote contest basically you have to send
a video to 4 on our Instagram Twitter or
their forums etc using the hashtag fh
emote contest to basically possibly get
your emo in for honor and be forever
immortalized in to the game i'll leave a
link in the description down below if
you want to follow through with that and
honestly the video they're showing off
for the stuff was pretty comical i like
those two guys you'd be justin who
recently just came to the team and i
forgot the new guy's name but he's now
host of the warriors then incredibly -
incredibly talented guys I love them
both but yeah if you want to possibly
get your emo forever immortalized within
the game definitely use the hashtag and
send them a video and yeah guys that's
gonna be the end of the video hopefully
guys did enjoy nothing really crazy
today of course the patch notes would
have probably made this video a lot
longer but I'd rather I've talked about
it a couple days ago when it first
released as opposed to Thursday and get
you guys maybe not up to speed
immediately so I I do apologize fast
this is a shorter video ba guys like the
beef you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I covered the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes and
leaks if you want to be kept up to date
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss on an
update if I stay subscribe to the
channel my two most recent videos are
gonna be on screen if you guys do want
to check that out and that guys hope it
for girls today thank for watching the
video and peace out enjoy the rest of
your day and enjoy the patch
[Music]
you
[Music]